foreign
to everybody uh on the committee and
those and the public that are attending
this uh uh hearing on 5 21 before we get
into 5 21 just several announcements for
the the committee
um we will be hearing this bill first
today but following this bill there we
will break into a caucuses and so we
will be starting the exact sessions up
following the caucuses uh in that the
cauces I'm sure will last a good half
hour maybe a little bit longer uh so
that um for the public that you you
don't have to sit through and wait you
can go wander the halls or whatever
um so with that I'd like to open up this
hearing 4 5 21. this is a bill relative
to the Department of Education payment
for placement for an episode of
treatment
um welcome representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and members of
the education committee for the record I
am representative Erica Leon of Derry
and I'm delighted to be back in front of
this committee uh with my experience
serving on this committee now in health
and human services and being on my
physical Advisory board for my school
district one of the areas that I have of
interest is to find where we're making
local taxpayers pay for health care and
get that out of the local taxpayers
obligation and get it to the state
getting it to the Department of Health
and Human Services or whichever bucket
is the correct one because local tax
school rate taxpayers should not be
paying for the health care of those
students the department came to me with
this bill because there is a current
issue with the system of care we
actually have as I'm sure you're all
aware we have an issue with boarding's
children who are going through
troubling mental times possibly suicidal
and they're being boarded in hospitals
on their way to to a placement there is
current there's an existing system where
with a court ordered placement they
could be placed into a facility and that
would be paid for by this Department of
Education there is a new voluntary
program that was recently created but
there's no funding mechanism for that
expense to be paid by the department and
it's currently born by local taxpayers
this bill would address that issue
um and I'm delighted that I can have any
small role in this I don't actually
understand all of the full details so I
will turn that over to Rebecca Fredette
the state director of special education
services but I hope that you'll look at
this as one of the potential Solutions
of untangling that mix between health
care and education and sending the bill
where it really truly deserves to go
thank you very much represent Leon
um I know you have to be out of you very
quickly I do too and I know represent
Miler is already probably no he's not
represent Lunas out of here and instead
I have a question have you been in
contact with the department so you can
get a better understanding of what kind
of fiscal Impact Physical note this is
going to result in it I know there
it says right here for this bill has to
introduced at this time when complete
the fiscal note will be available have
you had any approximations of what type
of dollars we're talking about here
um thank you I don't have those dollars
right now that's something that I can
get back to you before you have this
scheduled for an executive session these
same students if they went through the
the more time intensive process for a
court ordered placement would end up
being paid by the department
um
the question is do we through voluntary
agreement do we get this treatment
sooner or do we make them go through
this process thank you
further questions from the committee
yes represent cordelli
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for bringing this forward
um if I'm looking at this correctly the
two agencies involved DHHS and doe
um
DHHS would be involved in terms of the
costs
if it was the child was other than a
special needs child if it is a special
needs child then the cost would be
covered by the Department of Education
is that understanding correct
possibly I think that'd be a better
question for the director of specials
Education Services thank you for the
questions from the committee
thank you very much
thank you
but that I'm also going to be leaving
I'm going to represent cordelli will
take over the meeting do we have any
other cards on this one we have
so Department of Education Rebecca
you're at that
good morning thank you representative
Vlad and the committee my name is uh
Rebecca Fredette I'm the state director
of special education
we've asked for the change in RSA 193 27
to add the definition of an episode of
treatment and in RSA 186 c18 I believe
you have my statement in front of you
and then it does have an attachment
which is technical assistance that we
provide to the districts regarding
um this exact thing we're going to talk
about
um an episode of treatment as defined by
our proposal is when a child needs to be
placed at the by the Department of
Health and Human Services in a DHHS
contracted and or certified program to
receive more intensive treatment and
supports and has the objective of
helping children in crisis avoid or
reduce the use of psychiatric hospitals
and emergency rooms these their these
placements are determined through dhhs's
integrated system called the system of
care it's been developed in the last few
years some of you may be
um familiar with it and specifically the
fast forward program while these
determinations are made in the best
sense of interest of the child they are
not considered an IEP team placement and
therefore our district is not able to
access their idea funds to support the
placement nor have they budgeted for
these placements
this is very similar to our current RSA
186 c19b whereby the state provides Aid
through our court ordered placement
funds within this fund once the district
has paid three times the estimated State
average expenditure per child
all expenses beyond that will be covered
by the court ordered placement funds
these cop funds currently cover children
in placement for which the Department of
Health and Human Services has the
financial responsibility
in this past year there have been 50
Children placed through this system of
care districts have struggled with this
process as it is outside the idea
process and is not part of an IEP team
decision
where the educational decisions are made
regarding the needs of the child
educationally the current expectation is
that this number will increase Over time
however it is also expected that the
number of court ordered placements will
decrease moving forward and I forgot the
words will decrease on the on this while
you are while we are supportive of the
necessity for the system of care and the
decisions made in the best interests of
children we would ask that this RSA be
changed to support these placements as
we do our court ordered placements
thank you uh questions from the
committee
uh yes representative Damon
thank you Mr chair good morning thank
you for taking my question
could you just explain why these
placements are not part of this standard
IEP process so
um you can only place a child if the IEP
team has determined that this is
appropriate for their educational needs
so you may have a child that is goes to
school and is fine they have their IEP
implemented they the district has never
thought of placing them somewhere else
it's not an issue there and then because
of their issues at home or mental health
issues they do get placed in one of
these facilities well we CA it wasn't
based on a need for their disability it
was based on another need and so we're
not able to pay for that placement
through that the team are what we have
suggested in the technical assistance is
that that IEP team convene and discuss
the placement and say is this a
placement we would have placed this
child based on their needs within our
facility if they determine that it isn't
they cannot pay for it with their Ida
funds or their special education funds
foreign
there are times I will clarify though
that there are times that
um maybe the child has been having
difficulty in school and they just
haven't gotten to the point where
they're going to place them and so there
are occasions where the district will
say we were headed in this direction
anyway so yes we agree and we will start
to pay for this but all of that would be
at their own cost it would not be part
of a court order placement payment that
we provide to them as part of that
process
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here could you please define other
needs that would be beyond the idea
so what kinds of things would have been
sure
um I don't know if my uh my colleague
Rebecca Ross from DHHS can Define this
much better but I will give you the
information I know I don't believe she
um was able to attend today so there are
times when a child may be suicidal or
they may be violent at home and they're
a threat to their family but they may
not have
um this going on at schools because we
need to focus on what the educational
portion which is what Ida says you look
at how is this impacting them
educationally they may be doing fine
they may be going home and saying I want
to kill myself I you know unfortunately
not a good thing but they may be saying
that or they may be violent towards
their siblings and the family needs
assistance so they reach out to the um
fast forward program and say I need help
and then fast forward helps them to
determine what kind of assistance they
may need and in in some cases in this
case it would be that they are placed in
a facility to to support their needs but
it doesn't it isn't impacting them
educationally which is where we have
this it's the same as if a student was
placed by dcyf um and we cut and they
have the court order we pay for that
through our court ordered placement
funds
and represent Tanner thank you and thank
you for taking my question I uh a
question about the funding uh the
funding part coming out of doe
um and I don't even pretend to know how
that whole funding situation on special
ed goes but I I do know that there's a
certain finite pot that
um is then prorated for disbursement for
to to special ed and I'm just wondering
does this money come out of that pot
that finite pot so it makes the pro
rating less
and is it also out of the educational
trust fund
thank you for the question
um that what you're referencing is our
special education Aid pot
um and that it does have a finite amount
of money and it does come out of the
educational trust fund
um the court ordered placement money
does not have a finite amount of money
and I would have to ask Caitlyn what pot
of money it comes out of because I'm not
clear on that one
yes so just to be clear in my own mind
um if this goes through it's not going
to make any significant difference in
what reimbursement schools will get now
uh from proration after this goes
through because it's two separate two
separate
um accounts okay thank you
representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um would a would a student and I have
two parts to this question because I
don't know
um if a student has an episode and has
to be hospitalized could they then be
eligible for a 504 plan at that time and
my second part is if they are
is there funding that could be accessed
to provide that so this is so this bill
is only for students who have been
identified with a disability
um through idea and have an IEP so it
wouldn't be for students that are 504 I
believe that DHHS pays for students who
are not in special education they paid
the whole thing for any of the students
that are not in special education thank
you
representative Cornell Thank you for
taking my question so if if they're
hospitalized and they are an IEP but the
IEP isn't for what they're hospitalized
for who pays for that right now without
this bill DHHS okay but they yeah but
there's no I don't know how they pay it
but I wouldn't want to speak to that so
it gets paid for by the state it's not
something that like say it's a student
for me or Chester it doesn't come
Manchester doesn't have to pay for it no
okay thank you okay
further questions I just have a oh yes
representative Balboni thank you Mr
Sharon thank you for taking my question
um so if it isn't coming so what funds
are coming out of the district then
for the um currently if they determine
so there's the two scenarios if they
determine it's not something they would
have done for an IEP then they do not
pay anything currently if they do
determine it is something they would
have paid for through the IEP they pay
for the entire educational portion of
the placement with no assistance from us
um they could they could go to special
education aid but then that goes back to
Representatives Tanner's concern about
um making that proration for special
education Aid um less to each School
thank you
um just for my own clarification
possibly
um
if the student is a special needs
student
but
the placement is outside of idea outside
of their disability such as you said a
threat is home or something
I thought I also heard that since that
child is a special needs student the
Department of Education would pick up
the cost
am I mistaken in that
um I'm not aware of that okay
um
but so to clarify the school district is
still responsible for the provision of
special education if they are placed so
they ensure that they um collaborate
with whatever school that is that the
child has gone to and ensure that either
they're sending somebody to provide
services to the child or that they're
working with that school to ensure that
special ed is provided
so
um
if the placement is made by DHHS and
they are a special needs child but the
placement is not a result of their
special needs then the cost would be
picked up by DHHS yes thank you
any further questions yes representative
Damon
thank you Mr chair and please tell me if
this isn't an appropriate request
could there be a fact sheet that lists
the various scenarios and who currently
covers them sure because I'm finding it
hard to take this off it is definitely
and get it straight yes it is very
confusing that would be very helpful
thank you
any further questions
oh yes representative Lakers
thank you
thank you for answering this to follow
on with what he said
if we don't pass this bill
and so the way it is currently if
the child has an IEP but that doesn't
include the same placement but
um DHHS decides the placement like for
the example which you said
um then the school district itself
because it's not in the IEP would have
to pick up
all of the what costs so they would have
to so they would have to pick up the
costs if they determined that that yes
it is an appropriate placement based on
their special education say they've
already been having difficulty with the
child they've been trying to determine
what's the best way to support the child
and when that placement happens they are
supposed to have an IEP meeting and they
say we were already headed in this
direction anyway we're going to agree to
this yes they would pick up the entire
cost of of that or they would apply for
special education Aid which would then
make that proration even less first
districts and
oh I'm sorry yes just
but if we if they
if the issue isn't related to their
disability
like problems at home or suicidal or
whatever
and we don't pass this how is how is the
money and spending divided up
so then it would if they determined that
it was not part of the IEP currently
DHHS is
um paying for that but it was not
something that they had planned on
um so I'm not sure they would have to
ask them about their financial situation
in relation to this okay thank you okay
thank you Mr chair
um thank you Becky just a last question
for me is do you have any data on how
many students are the number of students
that
um
fall under these episodes of treatments
that don't get
financially paid either by DHHS or
um or state funds or not because it's
just started so it's been it's been a we
had to put the TA out to assist with
districts and make sure that they knew
what we were what was supposed to happen
so with the 50 kids that have gone I
don't believe that's that's all kids not
just students with disabilities right
and I don't know the number of how
they've determined that I would I would
have to reach out to every district and
say you know how many yeah
follow-up follow thank you
so is there any cost that a parent has
to bear on that
um that would be a question for DHHS
because they determine that for their
fast forward programs yeah probably I
would assume so yes thank you yep
any further questions from the committee
I've seen none thank you very much
um
is there any other cards no other cards
is there anyone from Department of
Health and Human Services
see none
um no one else wishes to testify
thank you very much we'll
close the hearing
and I think we'll all be breaking for
our individual caucuses
um and we'll reconvene at a time to be
determined
yes
information
Bitcoin at this time go into executive
session for today uh
January the 31st and we have on
the docket here the first bill to
discussed today is 419 this is relative
to math learning community program
communities programs of community
college system and making appropriation
therefore I'm going to handle gavel over
to representative cordelli
thank you Mr chairman
um House Bill 419
relative to
the math learning communities program of
the community college system and making
an appropriation therefore and I call on
chairman Ladd for a motion yes I like to
make the motion OTP for 419. I'd second
that second by representative Miler
thank you discussion by the chairman uh
basically we've had a math learning
communities on the books uh previously
in in statute uh it's a program which
assists uh the teaching of mathematics
in the high school and and better
prepares students for the transition to
community college system and careers it
allows us to provide an alternative
track for grades 10 and 11 and 12 and it
also enables us to have an assessment to
better understand where students are in
terms of understanding algebraic
Concepts and principles at the end of
that 10th grade after algebra one and
then with parent permission school
counselor teachers
um decision can be made to track the
youngster students into the foundations
for mathematics and quantitative math
and quantitative math is of course it
passed they get their Collegiate credit
for the post-secondary they're all
prepared and we've seen success we have
38 high schools that have participated
in this in the past there's training
provided through this program we're
talking two hundred thousand dollars and
the training is provided by the
community college system by the Beth
Dorian that's over there at the
community college system in the summer
we have we pull teachers down from this
high schools into the Community College
train them we have teachers teaching
teachers they go back with materials all
the materials are provided through the
program
so I would encourage that we move
forward with this bill
uh any comments by the secondary
no just I do have some numbers here I
was talking with Rick earlier for 419
for those who who signed in online you
had three that supported it and no no
opposition
thank you
uh discussion on the bill by the
committee
uh president woodcock
thank you chairman cordelli let's
generalize the question on the effective
date uh is is this is this July 1
uh
is it if this goes through and through
both houses and the governor would be
Levy time enough to cover next Falls
classwork
I believe was a community college system
and the appropriation of dollars which
they have I think it's timely
um we have the because part of this is
already in statute right so it would
just it just it's going to provide us
the green light of pursuing this program
I think all the the statutory uh is
basically in place uh so I think it's
possible okay um if we see something
going on as far as the time in this
there's the opportunity that I'm I'm
I'll see more teacher recruitment for it
that's all yeah okay yeah I think we're
okay thank you thank you chairman
cordelli
thank you uh representative cascaden
thank you representative
um my question is the funding for this
program is it for two years just
just two years or is it going to be
sustainable
I have to look at the bill
the RSA is 4 25.
I think it is two years I think during
that time though we have the opportunity
to watch this program and then go
further with it
it's something that we're using the Next
Generation accuplacer uh is that the
right tool I I've been told by the
Community College it is for the high
school however there may be some tweaks
and changes that come out of having
teachers uses for two years and and I
think at that time we can make it uh
the funding will course change
yeah
further questions comments
uh see no
if the clerk is ready we'll proceed with
the Roll Call
Ellie yes
representative leckis
yes
representative Ford
representative Belcher
yes
representative dry
representative McDonald
yes
representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Myler
yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno
yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes representative
chair lad yes
is there any objection to consent
we can do it it's a small you know
you're talking 200 Grand
which
20 zip right 20 years
okay
for the the for those in the public and
on the committee when I hand the capital
offer that gives me the opportunity to
make the motion but the Gap will then
upon my making a motion can be handed
back and and because we're not hearing
something we're not taking testimony I
can continue to run the meeting
so uh the next bill which we have is are
you already Madam Clerk
we're just gonna not rush you
okay thumbs up
HP 542 establishing the academic
research and Improvement performance a
data analyst in the Department of
Education I hand the gavel over to
representative cordelli
thank you Mr chairman uh House Bill 542
I would call on chairman lad for a
motion yes I'd like to make a motion for
542 OTP
okay
go with it thank you
so so taking that back represent Ladd
made the motion second by representative
Cornell
and discussion
uh we've had a lot of discussion on this
uh academic research and Improvement
performance Analyst at the department we
feel that the department in this regard
is very very understaffed with just one
individual there with Dr Nate green this
will better help us understand and
interpret the data we're getting back
from the Statewide assessment it also
allows us to get down into the weeds
track cohorts and to train and work with
folks out in the school districts
yesterday when I met with the
superintendents over the Capone Center
they were very excited about this bill
knowing that they may get some support
this is smaller districts don't have
this type of a support to really get
down and do this this will provide them
information and possibly save dollars
out in the field whereas if you're
seeing a weakness in one of your subject
areas you don't have to dump the whole
program you can try to determine where
in the program you need some changes and
this analysis analyst will help you work
and accomplish that and thank you
sure
recognize representative Myler uh yes
the electronic sign in was for support
and for a post okay
thank you
representative Cornell you were the
second on that I just remember from all
my years of being in a school getting
back the information it would be so
helpful to have somebody help you design
you know how to work with the areas that
you know your school scored low on or
even individual students
so this would be very helpful
further discussion from the committee
not seeing any uh Madam Clerk
we're going to be calling the roll here
now on 542 establishing an academic
research and Improvement performance dad
performance data analyst in the
Department of Education
representative cordelli yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford
yes representative Belcher
yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative courtiello
yes representative Myler yes
representative Cornell
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
28 zero knees
once again is there any problem with
consent
thank you we'll put it on consent if the
clerk someone's teams and you'll see it
elsewhere but I think we're going to be
good with it alrighty
the next bill which we have I'm just I'm
going to slow down here a little bit for
our Clerk
good I can remember as a clerk myself
I was always a bill behind and trying to
figure out so I still have to fill in
the title there oh yeah
all right HB 334 relative to to
determination and cost of a state
adequate education uh recognized
represent uh
no no yes okay representative Noble for
a motion I'd like to make a motion to
itl
is there a second I'll second that okay
representative luno made that second
and
recognize representative Noble the maker
of the motion
um so this bill would
um raise the base adequacy Grant from
3866.18 to
9517.4 Cents by taking half of the
average uh Statewide cost per pupil
I have nothing else is that it yeah
thank you thank you very much
representative luno
so thank you thank you very much Mr
chair and and uh and I'll be quick on
this as a lot a lot we can say on it but
we've actually got a full committee work
session I think scheduled for tomorrow
on a number of school funding bills but
I think everybody in this um around the
table here appreciates how how
complicated
um the school funding uh uh school
funding matters are in New Hampshire and
that a one-size-fits-all approach to
school funding uh is uh is not
necessarily is is not going to do the
trick and um and it certainly leaves out
many school districts uh especially the
one that um that representative
cascadden
um had had led uh for so many years up
in up in Berlin so um so I appreciate
the the prime sponsors the intent behind
this but look forward to working with
the sponsor down the road as we as we
tackle this um this problem thank you
huge problem
huge consideration are this further
consideration for me represent Miler uh
just again the electronic uh on this
submissions were 42 support 7 opposed
okay president represent Ellison oh
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
reinforce what representative Bluetooth
said that this is a complicated issue
but that that bill moves us right in a
very strong Direction and that when
we're doing getting together and we're
looking at various bills and trying to
make sense out of this that we in fact
do include the prime sponsor of this
bill and those discussions thank you
thank you further discussion on the deal
not seeing any uh Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative paternal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Miler representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
28 zero knees
thank you very much uh consent
thank you we will put that on consent
uh the next bill which we have in front
of us today for executing here going
back to the front side here is 364.
I'm going to wait for the clerk to catch
up to us
foreign
are you good yep
thank you okay 364 is relative to
transportation for students attending
Career and Technical education center so
I'm going to hand the gavel off to
representative cordelli
uh thank you Mr chairman uh house bill
364. I call on representative Vlad for a
motion I make the motion of OTP
the second by representative Cornell
thank you very much representative
Cornell
um
I'm
okay excuse me I'll go ahead and speak
as the maker of the motion uh this is an
issue that
um Career Technical Education Centers
and working with the directors and all
the the centers in this state over 20
and then and we also have an issue with
five of them being across the river in
Vermont
and are sending the students from the
sending schools to the
um the career tech centers we are
sending approximately I'm just going to
use rounded off figures we have about 10
000 students attending of which 8 000
students live and reside in The District
in which they have the CT Center and go
to the high school in that CTE Center
about 2 000 students are sent via
transportation from a sending school to
the receiving Center
and the way we reimburse Transportation
right now is at 10 cents per mile per
pupil on these buses that is really
tough for our school districts are
sending especially smaller all districts
all districts they're sending on one of
these multiple passenger yellow buses uh
elementary kids 66 kids on that bus and
we may have three or four kids that are
going to the CTE Center because that's
the space are the seats available for
that CTE youngster student
and so it's really turning into a
tremendous unfunded uh a cost that's
been hammered down to the local school
districts and we recognize that and it's
also causing some uh school districts uh
say we can't afford to send these kits
and that's something we don't want
either so we're looking in this bill
another way of establishing the
reimbursement formula currently we fund
CTE centers at nine million dollars per
year and out of that nine million
dollars we first take out the
transportation costs and we do it via
that formula 10 cents per mile it adds
up close to seven hundred thousand
dollars six hundred eighty thousand
dollars per year
and the remainder of the money is then
used for tuition costs and we want to
have more kids participate but the more
kids participate then our tuition costs
are being hammered because we have to
prorate those monies around just the the
growing numbers so the rescinding
districts receive less and less as a
result so this entire formula needs a
good strict look at and we're suggesting
that this bill go in effect in July 1
2025 it gives the department time to put
in place the the the recommendations
which are coming forth in the in the
statutory language is coming forth that
Transportation be based upon funding
reimbursement based upon the type of
vehicle the mileage that's driven and
the number of trips which are made daily
this will make a significant difference
and of course there might be different
mileage costs there should be mileage
costs when we're talking about a van
versus a large school bus or or some
other means of transportation we do know
too that the the student that transports
themselves with the approval of the
ascending District it's at 25 cents per
mile and that's uh you know hard too so
this bill is certainly another attempt
working with our our school districts
our CTE centers the directors
to re uh you know reimagine how we're
going to be funding transportation and
this is how this bill is really a
replicate of what the Kansas State
Department of Education is doing for
their students and there's a number of
states which are doing just this other
than what 10 cents per mile which is is
hard to accept that thank you
uh is there it is
agree with what rep plaid said being on
the advisory committee I think one topic
conversation that comes up a lot is the
the cost of transporting students and
how some districts students they just
decide not to allow the students to go
because they can't afford the
transportation and also we really
underfund CTE
other than Transportation anyway just
looking at the handout that we had
gotten and comparing us to Delaware we
give 9 million and Delaware because 89
million to CTE so I think we have a lot
more to do yeah and the percentage of
kids that go to CT in Delaware are well
over 50 percent and ours is well below
well below 50 down in the teens and we
want more kids getting these skills they
come out with a skill they come out with
a job they come out with achievement
scores and on average five percentage
points above those coming out of the
regular High School
and and uh there's a whole lot of
different programs which we're unaware
of and we don't really see what these
CTS are teaching now when I was at a CT
Center down in Salem where uh director
Dodge works I can remember talking to
one of the girls I saw in a classroom
there and this is a you know the old
vocational school but this is not the
vocational school this is a high-tech
school and she was majoring in in
medical uh areas dealing with Computer
Sciences Etc and I said where are you
going to go to school next year she said
ah I've already been accepted early
acceptance Virginia Tech
and and so we need to encourage this and
we need more kids attending our CTE
centers without a doubt so I I support
representative Cornell what she's doing
over there I was on that Council too and
I can remember every year we're looking
at the next thing it's going to come
down the road is tuition
and we're going to have to reimport
reverse more for tuition if we actually
fund Transportation the way we should
fully fund it it'd be
2.6 million dollars rather than the six
hundred thousand dollars to really
support the whole nine yards we're
talking more but we're taking it step by
step here and going after the tuition
right now
uh yes the uh the electronic uh
responses were six support zero opposed
representative woodcock
thank you chairman here are you talking
about the various CTE commission uh
programs I just say to throw in a little
uh public relations piece here for
Conway and our newest program are highly
successful is Aviation they're flying
they're getting pilot licenses they have
simulators they use the regular plane to
the airport it's terrific and they're
going into Eli's work as Clinton knows
in drone work yeah yeah and thank you
very much what represent Woodcock and
they've also developed some Hardware
which has gone up with NASA and at
Kennett they're doing a wonderful job up
there it's one of the centers that I'd
love to be living in and and have send
my own kids to it because there would be
a job waiting for them
by the way the last 747 came off the
line yesterday and that's it
representative Hall
thank you chair
um when we talk in committee we uh
talked about the effective date
of 2025 and we talked about why not 2024
are we still sticking with 2025
it's
I I think what we're we're going to be
crowding it a little bit this is a
Formula which there they may come up
with tweaking that formula a little bit
uh so I I didn't change that date if the
doe feels they can do that this is going
to go to another committee uh it's going
to go to the Senate and we can change
the date there so I think the best thing
for us do is move it now and ask that
question representative Hall uh later on
in a couple months here we can still
change that yes great thank you it's a
good point
further discussion
Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis
yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes Representative no
yes
foreign
yes representative Myler lunch
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative Cascade yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes yes yes
28 is zero names
all good with consent thank you
I'm going to jump over the next bill
and go to 272 and open this bill up HB
272 is increasing Charter Public School
per pupil funding
so I'm opening this bill up
and
we're going to close it right off here
we're not going to take any action on
this one today but we are in exact
session on this bill and so we will be
coming back and let me explain to people
that we're all recognizing that this
bill has there is a need behind it
however
it's tied into a number of other bills
dealing with per pupil costs not just
Charter Schools but elsewhere and we're
looking at the possibility of tying this
thing together with other legislation
so that will have to be done when we
deal with other legislation as well so
we're going to not exact that today and
we're going to close the hearing on
I'm going to address the second to no to
recess we're going to recess this to a
time to be announced so we will go then
on to
go check on copies for 103 and 147
magnets that I have
yeah let's go on do 577 also right now
because uh this bill is very similar to
what we just did relative to state aid
for special education pupils I like to
open this up and and have discussion
we're not I'm not going to take any kind
of recommendations at this time but I'd
like to have a little bit of a
discussion on it other than myself this
is a BL 577 relative to State a for
special education pupils and what it's
doing in a nutshell we have what we call
special education Aid it's what's called
catastrophic Aid there's a specific
formula on how districts that have
students with disabilities that have a
need for a real intensive training in
this area and maybe and definitely even
residential placement or or Hospital
placement there's a lot to this it's a
very important bill and the way the
formula works and then we'll have a
little discussion on it is that it's
based upon the average cost per pupil to
multiply that by three and a half times
so I'm going to say hypothetically the
average cost of twenty thousand dollars
before a District's going to even start
receiving any support for this other
than through differentiated aid for that
student which is a little over two
thousand dollars
they're going to have to go to three and
a half times that average cost Source
they're going to have to expend seventy
thousand dollars before they're going to
be eligible to receive any kind of
catastrophic Aid then for the next
portion up to 10 times that they're
going to receive
20 support of that
um the 80 is paid by the state and above
10 times the state takes over this is a
huge cost districts huge cost is built
we recognize
that that it's really a a a a mandate
that goes drops down to local districts
to make sure that you pay these initial
costs so I'm going to drop it right
there and open up for a discussion from
representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and um and
thank you very much for um for uh
allowing this committee to uh to hold on
to the last bill as well as this one
um
uh so that we can learn a little bit
more about it when it um when we heard
it last week
um it had a um it it did not have a a a
and you know and I I everybody's working
hard on these fiscal notes so I'm not
I'm not throwing anybody under the bus
but uh but it had one of those sort of
indeterminable fiscal notes and I think
it would be very helpful as you know to
to have a better understanding and maybe
if there's a way the department
might be able to look at
um look at you know back in the napkin
costing out going from the one and a
half Benchmark that this is at all the
way up to three and a half maybe in in
you know half Point
um
you know uh yeah increments
um we'd we'd at least be we'd be able to
have a um uh you know a series of costs
around it so we could do exactly what
you suggested
um um Mr chair which is um maybe one and
a half's not the answer maybe three and
a half's not the answer maybe it's
something in there and see how that fits
in with some of the other um school
funding
um legislation we're looking at I I
concur with you and not having that
fiscal note and this is a policy
committee got it
however the policy is that as a
recologist off the top of my I thought
we were talking uh in this category in
the Department's here approximately 760
kids in that what qualify for cat Aid
because specialized Aid
if you drop this down to three times so
you're taking that half off
of using the formula which you know I
just had a 20 brand you're talking ten
thousand dollars multiply that times to
760 what do you come up 7.6 million
dollars or something like that
roughly my my grade school math 760 at
that point pardon me it's not 760. the
number of kids
students but that are three times yes
it's going to be more and that's that's
the point I'm saying is that that trying
to say that we know it's going to be
more than that seven million dollars
it's going to be more than that and
that's what we don't know as you drop it
down from three three and a half to
three to two and a half to two to one
and a half one what does that mean in
terms of gaining more students that
qualify for this and what are the costs
we don't have that information
and sending something on the finance
I'm I'm fearful that Finance you know
we'll be looking at the dollars and I'm
trying to also look at the policy behind
this do we have to tweak other areas of
this program too
um do you reach full funding uh a little
later on in the game and rather than
going eight times you know or or the 80
range do we tweak that somewhere there's
a lot of places when this whole formula
that can be looked at policy wise in
terms of who's qualifying and for this
extra support or not and for that reason
I too cannot make a decision today I
don't have the information to do it and
so that's why I I'm not going to take
any kind of recommendation whether it's
up or down or retain it's an important
issue if we retain it we don't address
this thing till November and and we're
we're just
kicking the can down the road
um so it's time to really get a good
handle on so I would ask that if we're
able to get the data that both reps on
luno and I are asking for that will be
of tremendous help to us to try and
address a better policy answer on this
any other discussion from our committee
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just want to also
notice that
um along with playing with a three and a
half number and looking at the step
increments it may be worth us looking at
also looking at the um the 80 20
reimbursement percentage as far as
because that that seems to me that's
going to be the crusher for smaller
districts who have you know a small
number of very expensive students yeah I
I would I would agree with you that's
why I mentioned that portion too this
summer I think it was either July or
August I was called down to the office
here and I was talking with a community
that had a school board member there and
Leadership and they're saying wow we're
short 1.5 million dollars in this we
don't have it in the bank to help pay
for this residential cost and our costs
and and we're ending up having to take
this out of other other operational
areas within our budget and that's part
of the policy issue we're dealing with
other words this is a mandate in the in
the former of reimbursement is based
upon the previous year's spending and
and are re receipts and
so a district has to come up with this
if they don't have a reserve account if
they don't have that their small
District they are going to have to
figure out how to pay for this and
they're going to have to raise the
revenue
oftentimes they're looking at we might
be able to find some in our operating
budget and that's going to subtract from
programming that they're looking forward
to doing whether it's professional
development or it's usually labor costs
even bigger than that to try and make up
the difference so this has a lot of
policy implications to us and that's why
we need more time to try and filter
through this a bit
further discuss representative Damon
Damon thank you Mr chair I just want to
State a
optimism that we will address this
effectively so there's an improvement in
special education funding
not waiting for November or as you put
it passing it on
um these small districts really need
this help
imminently thank you
we are got we have a deadline on these
early bills we have to decide this issue
what we're going to do one way or the
other retain OTP itl by the 16th of
February
so yes it's not going to be kicked down
we got to do something
yes
okay uh so I'm going to
recess this to a time to be determined
here
and go on to the next bill which is HB
Madam clerk you might want to catch up
with us a little bit here 420 relative
to the availability and funding for the
Dual and concurrent enrollment program
by the community college system and
making an appropriation therefore
I'll hand the gavel off to
representative cordelli thank you Mr
chairman House Bill 420 I will call on
chairman Ladd for a motion
yes I make the motion OTP
second
representative Miler thank you
discussion
yes uh I'd like to very much
HB 420 has been a bill it's a topic
which we have discussed here for the
last five years or so for the concurrent
dual enrollment program and it's a
program with running start and restart
and Etc offered by our community college
in conjunction with high schools when
it's concurrent in Duo enrollment
um we've seen a lot of wonderful success
when we first started this program
and I've mentioned to the committee
before when I I worked with uh
uh Chancellor Ross cattell
and Todd Leach uh the four-year system
which the four-year system begged not to
get involved with it seeing that they
could not provide this at the cost at
the tuition cost that the uh community
college system was offering and that we
were expecting
and so we went ahead and we budgeted
that year close to 1.5 million dollars
or so 600 and I think 650 000 first year
950 000 the second year and tremendous
response for grades uh 11 and 12
students and it was centered around stem
students stem courses
and we went the direction of the stem
courses initially seeing that we knew we
didn't have enough funding available for
everything and so we narrowed it
narrowed the focus down
and and so with that over the years
we've done some changes we've tweaked
the program now so students in grades 10
11 and 12 can participate and we've
upped the ante as far as how much we've
supported the the the concurrent dual
enrollment program in this bill
uh request what is it
3.25 million dollars per year to support
this program but it also opens the
program up
to all courses uh that you know be on
stem which is an important item in fact
that there's many students that don't
want to take a science
or technology course or a math course
they just like to get a few basic
college courses under their belt find
out what it's all about they may be the
liberal arts type courses however once
they're in there they're finding I can
do this it's just like when we initially
required the SAT to be given to all kids
and the main they found out by mandating
the sat in the 11th grade the kids which
are taking the SAT all sudden found wow
I got a score which is a pretty decent
score I can go to college and so Maine
immediately saw more students choosing
to opt go that pathway rather than
jumping out right after high school and
looking for a a skill or a job to to
work in I think that's what this program
does it also does the very important
thing which I I think was really
appreciated
we keep more students in the state of
New Hampshire by getting students
engaged in the community college system
early on in the 10th grade 11th grade
and 12th grade they can come out of
there now taking up to five courses a
year and come out with a real good
background and and go into a two-year
degree with a year already knocked off
or go into the four-year system which we
of course is now after what we did last
year which are mutually agreed upon for
transfer from the community college
through the high school I mean to high
school to the for your system so this
has been really beneficial the first
year we did this by spending that 1.5
million we estimated that we were able
to say parents from having the expense
of having to pay for these colleges upon
college courses after graduation at that
time the savings to parents was 6
million dollars when we did the estimate
of what this was saving by having the
courses 150 bucks paid for by the state
while they're in Cal in in high school
so I'll stop right there I feel it's an
excellent program we mimicked it or took
a lot of the initial stuff from Wyoming
where they have seven community colleges
out there we have seven community
colleges here and they were in
concurrent dual enrollment and these
concurrent dual enrollment programs are
recognized we we ensure that they're
taught in the high schools at the
national standards that we have
established as a country and in
conformance with what the community
college requires and New England
Association of schools and colleges
requires that you have a master's and
that you have the professional
background in the area that you're
teaching so that is a real uh good point
also so thank you very much
uh the second was made by representative
Miler uh yes I just uh I don't want to
take much of our time on this but just
to reiterate uh what chairman Latta said
that this has been a proven program I'm
pleased that this expands the
opportunity for students to experience
the programs uh Beyond just the the stem
issues and it also provides an
opportunity for students to have some
experience from a college course
standpoint plus as the chairman Ladd
said it also provides a financial
incentive for students to take these
courses I know I've often looked at the
two young men that were what were our
neighbors and they were home like at one
o'clock in the afternoon and I'm saying
well isn't there something else for them
to do and so this provides an
opportunity for them to fill their
schedule and take their academic time to
a different level thank you very much
thank you very much is there further
discussion on this bill
not seeing it yes nope not seeing any uh
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis
yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher
no
representative dry yes
representative McDonnell
yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
19 years one day
thank you very much this one has a big
Financial note
and so this will not go on the consent
calendar week if it didn't have the
financial note you can put bills on or
17 to 1 or 16 to 2 or whatever once you
get down to about three members then an
office and we start thinking about
putting it on on the rigor calendar so
this will be on the regular calendar
excuse me okay
I get my sheet here I got very
[Music]
foreign
papers up here I've buried my agenda
three
yeah it must take me out okay we we are
right
here
we could do this one right here 365.
that's the next one up that's that's um
okay where the next bill we're going to
do is HB 365 relative to the Statewide
facility condition assessment for school
buildings
behind the doc uh the Cavalier
uh thank you Mr chairman uh this is
House Bill 365 and I call upon chairman
laad for a motion uh yes thank you very
much I would make the recommendation of
OTP for HP 365. second uh representative
Miler makes the second
uh discussion by the chair yes
um
some people might ask why I'm making the
motions all these bills are my bills and
I've got the blurbs already written and
so we're ready to fly on them
um save a lot of effort in somebody's
part uh HB 365 is uh dealing with the
Statewide facility condition assessment
uh and it's it's tying into the skill
school building uh aid program which we
have and in that language where the
statute mentioned School building a one
of the requirements which we had put in
place was we want to have a 10-year
Capital plan for our school building
facilities what we have out there so the
state
will have a better idea of planning and
appropriating dollars uh for a state
school building Aid and that's what this
program does it doesn't mandate that you
have to have your plan in place but it
encourages school districts to submit a
plan or where they're going in the next
10 years so we can better build the
state plan so that we will have an
understanding of where we're going in
terms of school building a everybody's
familiar with that we appropriate up to
50 million dollars each year for school
building Aid which currently half of
that we're right at that point now we're
half of that still is going towards the
uh paying off our previous debt
and so so during the upcoming biennium
we'll be approving 100 million dollars
which 50 million dollars is going to go
to paying debt and 50 million dollars
for new facilities which are tentatively
allocated for Rochester Colebrook and
Monadnock elementary schools
we have a laundry list of buildings that
are coming to us that are required
asking for consideration in this process
applications have been received by
Department of Education which total over
500 million dollars of which our share
is over a little over 200 million
dollars when you take the 30 to 60
percent
obviously with that districts are seeing
they have needs even though we're going
through a time where the demographic in
the state has declined over the last 10
or so years from 210 000 students to 160
something thousand students uh that
doesn't mean that all districts are like
that it doesn't mean all districts have
current buildings which are modern
buildings that are going to facilitate
the needs and demands of today's
educational programming we know many do
not we know that many are over 50 years
old over
60 years old now and this is
um not uncommon we know that there's
places where remedial reading is being
taught in the locker room of the showers
I saw that myself in Allenstown several
years back we did when we did a little
trip over there with some minor if you
recall and that was a a sad thing to see
kids getting training in a shower room
for reading and at lunch time you can
smell everything that was being cooked
in that kitchen throughout that entire
building and the ventilation system in
that building was not good
so we have these needs and yes we do
have extra money and all that which can
help limited area on HVAC but that's the
extent of where that can be used we need
to really step forward and this is a
first step on school building a program
bills that you're going to see coming
forward this year this is just the front
edge we're going to be looking at a
total application process we've got to
look at the financial process which I've
already been heard by finance and so
this is just a policy consideration that
we need to get going on we need to have
a better understanding what's out there
and we need to work with these districts
and trying to get this 10-year plan
meaning something thank you very much
uh representative Milan yes you're good
yes representative cascaden thank you uh
you're right we have so many schools
that are
um really need a lot of renovation
um we have K to five in an old high
school building that's a hundred years
old with staircases that you wouldn't
even think of using yourself but
nonetheless I there is a great need to
know that and anticipate and the state
should know where different districts
are because building Aid is extremely
difficult to acquire
I just I wonder if
um this is going to be a requirement of
school districts to add that to their
maintenance staff or whoever is
responsible for buildings
and I just wonder if the commissioner or
the department would develop a template
for that assessment that would make
things consistent across the state in a
little bit easier for staff to follow
um I don't know if you have that answer
or not but that that that would ease the
need for this assessment the yes it's a
good question it's good information uh
of course in this bill we're encouraging
districts to do this but the template is
going to be absolutely necessary we have
asked a the department in Prior years
Amy Clark
um
to
survey schools to find out what's out
there that survey has gone out but it's
you know it's General and it's being
completed by Personnel within the
schools some schools have a lot more
information on it seeing that they've
worked with engineers and Architects to
develop their site plans and they have
that others do not and and so we're
getting kind of mixed feedback on that
however what this bill will do and I
agree we do need to have some kind of a
template to assist the school district
saying hey we're looking at this we had
a bill
last two years ago and where we were
trying to appropriate 3.3 million
dollars for teams to go out and do that
assessment the teams would include an
engineer architect and a policy person
from the Department
that that uh was rejected by Finance
and we even though we had the the money
there it was in sort of what I call it
in the bank we had 1.3 million dollars
carryover from the public school
infrastructure fund and we had two
million dollars which is appropriated
for the next year this biennium we're in
so we had the 3.3 uh we had changed
course and we've used the 3.34 buildings
but for security issues and access
issues in our schools which is also
needed so The Next Step would be to try
to get these plans so there's more meat
to it by providing that support that we
are initially after I think it's a great
idea to send these teams out that's
happening in Montana right now where
they send teams out in States all across
this country they're going out doing
conditional assessments and looking at
technology they're looking at the shape
of the buildings in terms of delivery of
curriculum and instruction they're
looking at uh performance of energy in
the buildings use of energy and they're
looking at HVAC systems so they're
looking all that and they have some real
accurate data which we have sort of but
not really good data and you're correct
and representative cascadden I know you
know that as a superintendent and um so
this is really a step trying to
beef up the 20-year plan and I would
expect down the road we will shortly see
where we're trying to go after those
teams going back out this was
recommended years or years ago also when
Mark Joy Dr Mark Joyce was around and
again rejected because of the cost so
that's a long answer to your very good
question that's definitely the ideal
representative yes yep
further questions on this bill our
discussion not seeing any discussion uh
Madam chair would you please call the
roll
oh motion motion yeah motions
please excuse me
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative lekkis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative Corey
although yes representative Myler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes yep
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes
28 zero Nays
is there any objection to consent well
thank you we will put it on we'll put on
consent
and see where the report that we have
some left here lots of board members for
the uh and about the other one which is
the only one um
the the the special ad yeah this is our
Amendment for them to be correctional
facilities
oh
um
I think we have some amendments
um copies are being made I have an
amendment to that okay so okay we're
gonna go with 103 first we're jumping
around a little bit but we're going to
try and get one bill done here and then
we'll break a little early so people if
they have to get the capture you can
beat the crowd
I shouldn't say that publicly and so
that the others are going to hear it
they're listening they're on the way uh
so hb103
relative to school board member
qualifications
representative cardelli I I
let's see a motion uh thank you Mr
chairman I wouldn't move a lot to pass
and uh I would like to offer an
amendment as well
is there a second for ought to pass
okay you have an emotion
speak yes yeah thank you very much an
amendment yes the Amendments around
um
this this amendment is based on
discussion we had at the public hearing
uh there were questions about
um the individual uh situation where uh
it was within the same SAU but a
different School District
where the family member was involved so
this changes that language so that
they can
serve on the school board of the
district
in an SAU
if it's in other district from which the
family member is a employment
sort of voids that conflict about
um a family member in the same district
as the school board member
are there more but people down here
don't have me oh I'm sorry
so there's two on this one soon okay
there's one
I took 100 away but there's two records
thank you
you can see lines five through eight
are struck and um added in was 9 through
14.
foreign
this is the first time for everybody
with this amendment so uh what we will
do is we'll caucus for a few moments
here take as much time as you need
um let's go okay sure
done
um my Apollo my apologies I I make sure
everybody's mic is off
coming back in here we have before us uh
Amendment which we had put out for
discussion it's Amendment 0013h
for
hb103 uh it was presented by
representative cardelli he has not made
a motion on that uh representative
cordelli hi where are you on that yes I
would like to move
um amendment
2023-0013h
to uh house bill 103.
is there a second
represent Belcher
uh discussion represent cordelli thank
you
um as briefly discussed earlier
um there was discussion uh during the
public hearing and I think that this
amendment is being offered in relation
to that testimony in that it clarifies
that
um
an employee of a district within an SAU
may serve on a school board of a
district other than the district in
which they are an immediate family
member unemployed
and goes on to say that
um
there is uh the Mandate that they recuse
themselves of any matter involving
hiring terms of employment or
termination of the superintendent as all
discussed in the public hearing
I have a few questions about this but my
first question is
um the part that's that's actually uh
removed no person holding the office of
member of the school board Shell at the
same time hold the office of District
moderator or Treasurer or auditor
um with this amendment with this bill
does that then mean that people who are
moderator Treasurer auditor can be on
the school board
foreign
that that provision is is removed
uh as a follow-up
so I'm correct I could be the moderate I
could be the moderator or even the
auditor and and serve on the school
board
if you look further down in the new
section it can't be within the same
school district has to be in a different
District
doesn't that just apply though to the
salaried positions the teacher
professional custodian administrator
secretary bus driver
so the auditor could still be on the
school board
yeah thanks thanks very much Mr chair
and this is sort of a question too and
I'm and I'm looking down at line 17
through 19 where where the I think
you're you're referring to
uh people are in the immediate family of
the school board member
or prospective School Board member and
you've got child so if uh if if say a
school board member has a has a child
who's a student maybe in you know 10th
11th 12th grade and is being paid by the
district to tutor other other
um students than the school board member
are you saying that the school board
member would
I guess immediately is this like an
ejection seat like the school board
members no longer a school board member
if
if you know their their kid tutors and
other kids and paid by the district or
any of those other conditions
um exist
s within the same district
that's what I'm saying so yes
thank you Mr chair
um though I think this amendment does
improve upon the the foundational bill
it does seem that uh
given the provision that it would go
into effect 60 days after passage
um it may rather unfortunately put some
towns who may be in this position in the
situation of having to do impromptu
elections to fill seats on the school
board
very good point and something that
should be considered further discussion
representative uh Balboni
um yes I actually served on the school
board that had four different districts
and an SAU and one of the things that um
we know if you serve on a district
school board you're also automatically
serve on the SAU school board and a lot
of the just so in other words it says
that you would recluse yourself
from conditions of employment
termination of the superintendent there
are other Personnel involved in an SIU
board that also would dictate
things down to certain employers within
the district and that would include the
assistant superintendent special ed
directors so there's a lot of other
policies so in effect if you're serving
on the sou board
you really are we'd have to recluse
yourself from almost everything I would
think and that would put the district at
a disadvantage two of our district
boards only have three members the other
two have five and if you're one of those
districts that only have three
automatically a representation on your
uh your school district for your CU is
diminished thank you thank you further
discussion on this representative
cascadden thank you Mr chair
um I think I would want a little bit
more clarification on this
um as to what it does for the simple
reason that
most school districts if not all will
have a policy manual
and this particular policy BCB is board
member conflict of interest and nepotism
and I think these issues are addressed
in those local policies so I'm not sure
what this bill would do in addition to
what's already on the local policies
thank you
I would just say that we can't be sure
what all Local District policies are in
terms of nepotism or anything else
you're reading from one particular local
policy we can't know what every district
has for a policy
thank you are we at the point now where
we're ready to take action one way the
other on the amendment
so at this point in time uh Madam clerk
would you please call the role on the
amendment the amendment is
um
2023-0013h and the uh the emotion that
was for that amendment was to ought to
pass amend that to uh the original bill
which it was HB 103.
foreign
cordelli yes
Representative leckis no
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher
yes
representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no
representative pedernal
no
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no
representative Luna no
representative Ellison no representative
Luca no
representative Hall
now Representative balbooni no
Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd no
four years 16 knees okay so that most
that Amendment fails
we're now back at the main motion which
is to which is an ought to pass for
hb103
further discussion on that
now Kirk would you please call the roll
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leckis no
representative Ford no
representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pedernal no representative courtiello
now representative Miler nope
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Wilcox representative Hall Nell
Representative albioni no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman Ladd no
zero yays 20 Nays
is there a motion
mode no uh reps and Bell should you make
a motion
I'll make a motion for right heel
that second represent Miler yes
we have a motion for itl second by
representative Miler for the discussion
for anybody Prime smart
motion or maker and a second no not
seeing Madam clerk we have a motion on
the table to itl 103. uh we're ready
when you are ready
Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble
yes representative pedernal
yes representative cortiello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative lunao yes
representative Ellison yes
representative yes representative Hall
yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascad and yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes 28 years
thank you very much now we're going to
take a break here we're a little bit
into the lunch hour but it is uh 12
o'clock we'll come back at one o'clock
and continue executing
yeah is there any problem with putting
that previous bill on consent no no
so it's on consent
got that early yeah
did a great job that's the first time
we've gone through this and you're
wonderful thank you
that I know it I I live with a librarian
okay I'm going to move forward with our
executive session for this afternoon and
the first bill on the docket is going to
be hb309 which is relative to civil
rights education and public elementary
and secondary schools I call upon
representative Ford to make a motion
please
I feel Mr chair represent Ford makes the
motion of itl in 309 I will second that
motion Is there further discussion from
the make of the motion
you don't have to talk on it if you
don't want to
I'm sorry okay
um I second that motion and
um we've had this bill come before us in
previous years and uh I believe there's
certain topics which are over and over
and over and over and I think that
there's is it's basically curriculum is
a local issue on this one along with
instruction and my concerns are on a
bill like this how it's taught is pretty
much the key to it the instruction
component and statutory language any
change there's not going to change how
instruction occurs in the classroom
so further discussion on the bill
not seeing any further discussion on 309
uh
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll on 309 309
.
relative to civil rights education and
public elementary and secondary schools
Vice chairman cordelli
yes
excuse me itl is uh my my vote is no
the vote is itl well
no was the opposite
Representative leckis no
representative Ford
yes
representative Belcher no
representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble
no Representative pedernal no
representative course yellow no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative Cascade and
yes representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
12 years eight knees
thank you very much uh the next bill
which we will address marching down here
is hb103
uh no we did that excuse me we did that
one uh three seven seven we did not do
relative screening it's intervention in
public schools for dyslexia and Related
Disorders yes
well so you don't have that yet okay
uh the next bill
we may be looking for amendments on this
one too HB 147 uh relative to membership
of the advisory committee on education
of students with disabilities
I would
yeah I representative cardelli thank you
I I would move art to pass and I have a
uh an amendment
okay we have a move uh most made
octopass and there is an amendment
um
is there a send is there a second on the
ought to pass
we're not you know we need to have a
second note
okay and now representative cordelli
does say that he has an amendment to
this
um
Mr chair I also have an amendment but we
have two amendments okay good can we get
them both passed around please
and Mr chairman I have a an accompanying
document to go with my amendment that I
will pass around as well
okay are both these stockings together
here yes
in one of those and then one of these
and this is Tanners okay
one of these these these just keep going
that way
and
they're super
thank you
and this is a separate Amendment from
representative Tanner so there should be
three pieces of paper coming around that
way told
at this point
there's something else
that's part of the backup to cordelli's
in a movie
foreign
apparently they did yep
you should have two amendments one of
which says is rep uh representative
cordellis which is a zero two zero five
h on it
okay
this is a supporting document to
representative cordelli handed that out
do we have uh more of these anywhere on
either side
yeah represent Balboni has some of them
over there
two amendments
your amendments on the floor so
uh we I think we can have a discussion
of both visual just expedite times
is everybody good to go now with the
three piece of paper
okay I'm going to ask uh even though we
have one amendment that we you know are
debating right now
um I'd also like to have some discussion
involving the other one as well we're on
the same topic then we'll we'll vote on
the amendment uh there's been times in
the past this is just for information
that we've merged stuff together too and
made you know one but uh I haven't read
either of these I don't know if that's
even possible but not for this one not
with this one okay okay so would you
please explain yours first and and then
um
products have represent uh Tanner
explain hers
thank you Mr chairman
um
I served two terms on the advisory
committee for the education of students
with disabilities
currently the committee has something
like 36 members
it is completely unwieldy
some I have talked to on the committee
say it's dysfunctional
um
it it'll take a half an hour 40 minutes
to approve the minutes from the last
meeting
um it's hard to get things accomplished
um so my
Amendment
does add the health care provider as in
the original member
but revises the membership
down to what is required
under federal law under idea and that's
the supporting document that I handed
handed out with it it reduces the
membership to something more like 28
members so a little bit better
um but the other thing it I tried to do
in here I specify 14 individuals with
disabilities or parents of children with
disabilities
one of the requirements in federal law
is that parents have to be the majority
on the committee
that doesn't always happen now
very often that is not the case
so that is the other primary intent of
my legislation
I don't think that it drastically
changes that focus at all of the
committee in many cases it'll just
revise two members down to one member in
some instances
but I think it's entirely necessary for
the committee to be a functioning body
to actually accomplish things
thank you
thank you very much uh represent Tanner
why don't you just you know on the same
topic here so I could explain what
you're up to too with yours sure so the
underlying bill
was brought forward by representative
catab and
um it was she
was concerned about the committee that
there she would like to see a health
care provider on the committee a
pediatrician and in order to get the
pediatrician on the committee because
this representative cordelli has stated
it's a rather large committee and half
of it has to be parents
um
she took one corrections officer off
um as the the person that would be
deleted so that the health care provider
could be put in
my my Amendment simply specifies the
corrections officer that was taken off
in the underlying bill was at the State
Corrections
and uh had this I'm sorry the state
corrections person had been left on and
what was taken off was the County
Corrections person and the feeling was
for the amendment to put the county
person back in and take the state out
was that most children most youth who
are going to end up going through the
correction systems would start out with
some sort of issue with the county and
that the county person would be dealing
with the you know the 16 17 18 year olds
up to what is it 26 I think something
like that and at a lesser penalty
um stage catch them early and that the
so that's one part of the bill of the
amendment is just swapping those two
Corrections Officers that's in part cue
and then in part T where where the
healthcare provider was put back in
um just wanted to we talked about it in
committee actually about how nurse
practitioners and and other Physicians
might rather than just say a
pediatrician so this one has uh that a
physician or a nurse practitioner who's
licensed to practice in New Hampshire
but then that specializes in work
dealing with children with
neurodevelopmental disorders cognitive
and behavioral assessments and pediatric
learning disorders and this person is
appointed by the governor so it just uh
delineated so it wasn't just the local
family physician that maybe dealt with
maybe one child with disabilities this
person would have extensive knowledge in
that field so
that's that's the uh amendment that I'm
offering to the underlying bill
thank you representative cordelli uh
thank you uh thank you representative
Tanner um I would just point out uh if
you'll uh notice on my um supplementary
handout
um under 300 168 membership
um
11.
a 11
sites is a requirement uh
representatives from the state Juvenile
and adult corrections agencies
foreign
Corrections people on the original
committee was not correct
that question addressed to represent
cordelli said yeah yeah okay
because if you're asking me I don't have
a hot clue
the the uh the bill before I had this
the the the State Correctional
facilities and County
but I'm not aware what the federal says
it just says
um
representatives from the state Juvenile
and adult corrections agencies
yes
so the other question I think too and I
I guess I would address this to
representative cordelli
is that uh representative Tanner's
Amendment
is very specific
as relates to the
medical
um
medical representative on this committee
and whether or not he would have
problems because he basically just rep
you just mentioned a pediatrician and
representative Tanner says that the
practitioner should be one who basically
understands these kinds of issues not
just the GP that deals with uh with
pediatric issues that may not have an
understanding or an in-depth knowledge
of the disorders that are here would you
have a problem with uh an amendment
to your cue which just merely says a a
pediatrician
no you wouldn't have a problem with that
with with the change you're right taking
the 10 or q and putting that on my
whatever okay all right thank you
representative Damon
so if I could request if that
um part of the two amendments is merged
I think it should say pediatrician nurse
practitioner or physician's assistant
Physicians assistants and nurse
practitioners are different training
paths to parallel qualifications
represent pet now
thank you
representative Tanner do we know if this
a physician or nurse practitioner with
these qualifications is actually
practicing in our state and if so how
large is the pool of those types of
practitioners
that's a good question and and basically
it they didn't have to have it was it
was to point out that the person the
medical person had to be
um
not only license to practice but had to
be aware of these other other spots it
didn't I didn't necessarily mean that
they had to have every one of those they
could be in each one and and I also
thought that the physician's assistant
would be under a physician but
okay uh there were a couple of your
first then I'll get you representative
represent Hall you had your hand up
earlier uh thank you I was just going to
add just to say aunt or and then you'd
be all set on that on the Tanner
Amendment or the behavioral assessment
and the cognitive
pediatric learning disorder if you do an
and or they would just have to be one of
those
yes
um I realized just from I and I'm not in
depth on this at all
um that the mem the committee has way
too many members that it's um that has
been stated before I think um in the
cordelli amendment I I'm a little bit
um the person who's a representative
from the disabilities rights Center
being crossed off I I find that a little
bit hard harsh and also the parents
information center because I think those
are two areas where
um people get a lot of information and
and they know what's going on in the
legislature that sort of thing so I just
you know it's kind of a
I don't know a mishmash how you're going
to deal with this
yes representative cordelli thank you
um I would just if we were to add them
back in then we would have to add
parents back in and then we're pretty
much back up to where we are and
committee size currently right
testing
uh representative Woodcock thank you
chair my wife Roberta Cordell I'm
looking at line nine
talks about and you're a member of the
14 individuals and I'm looking at nine
third line 31 which seems to me to be
the same person or persons August 31
says they may have may have received
specialized services and it doesn't mean
they have to be received so it seems to
me the 14 in in line 9A and line of 31 H
could be combined because they're both
individuals they're both special ed and
they're both may and they're both
appointed by the governor that may still
be one I don't know the difference
between the two if there is one gland
I I would be open to some combination
thereof also just give you one spot back
they're both the same group
foreign
Hall
yes thank you I have a question of
Representative cordelli so when taking
off the disabilities rights Center and
the parent information center you served
on this committee did you feel like they
weren't really influential in this
committee they weren't necessary or
um
it uh
it depended on who the representatives
of those bodies were
sometimes they were valuable and
sometimes they weren't
you could put it you could put it that
way
represented like us
regardless of who we put on this
cannot other people be called in to help
so those people who wanted to come in
could still come in and give information
they just couldn't Vote or be part of
the Quorum or whatever is that correct
or not
yes we we had
people coming and testifying giving
their opinions uh other than members yes
I once served on this uh group once
before years ago
and I found it quite a formative task
one of which they always met in the
afternoon the day we had session
at four o'clock and you could never make
it down to Manchester to participate
with the group that was one of the
problems I think they've tried to
rectify that but I can remember meeting
and it was just a room full Chuck full
of people and it was not like this
committee which is smaller and you get
to know and and
what people represent I I just couldn't
discern what groups they were
representing
but the question I have for the
committee right now is that there's two
differences I see within the bill one is
going to one has kept the County
correctional facility and the other has
gone with the State Correctional
Facility
um my experience has been
that kids that students that come to the
or those that are put in for Corrections
at the county level and we do have a a
prosecutor here in our midst today
in the back share there but in the
county that I was in we we had uh folks
that came from all at Corners Grafton
County and we'd have the in the
superintendent of Corrections would have
to check to make sure that these people
had it for one had graduated from high
school two was there an IEP then you had
to track down the community in which
they were from seeing oftentimes they
are arrested in a different community
so that was quite a challenge in itself
then you have to find people to instruct
in accordance with the IEP and so the
the I think there's a real task in far
as County corrections as far as getting
this done and I think that's an asset
which I think that's uh would be needed
on this that's one area I'd make a
change to one of the Amendments uh so
and they in the County Corrections
I'd like to also know how many folks on
in County now are reading needing IEP
support we might be able to get that
from Rebecca
for that uh or somebody or doe I know
that our County Corrections load has
gone from the new jail which we have up
there which is a beautiful facility that
Ray Burton was able to acquire the money
for
it's built for 150 and we have about 47
to 43 in it and
in other words well that that's good and
you know but a lot of the others now are
on a probationary type status where
they're not getting that service in
their homes
uh and they've already dropped out of
school so there's I'd like to be able to
capture these um these students somehow
and I think that has to be
representation on this group
yes represent cordelli
um Mr chair since this is not an early
bill can we recess this to a future date
so that there could be some work on
Amendment
yes we can always recess this we have
not taken the action as of this point so
uh
represented dry
thank you Mr chairman can I ask a
question on the homeschooled person just
looking at the definition
appreciated we usually are lumped in
together with private schools and and
this is a special exception but it's a
very narrow category I mean it says it
doesn't say family that's homeschooling
that has a disability so could it be
anyone that represents this group or
someone from a a home education Group
which line are you looking at line eight
on the second page
letter m
for you
I I don't recall
um my time in the council who was
representing a homeschool Community
um
but reading this
um I think
um it could be anyone in the family
okay follow up I'm not even reading
family with what is here
representing yes okay
let me reiterate what I said there's so
many people in that room I didn't know
what they were representing
represent my way
uh thank you Mr chair and I would concur
with the idea of recessing this for more
work but I do have a question for every
time cordelli I'm concerned about uh
items uh 27 through 30 on your Amendment
and the first page
because we have had
people here and not so much this year
but in the past from the disability
rights Center and specifically from the
parent information center since these
are two groups
who on a daily basis are dealing with
disability issues from families Etc and
I I I'm just perplexed on why they would
be uh you you eliminated them I normally
full while you're trying to cut some of
the numbers down but they seem to mean
it would be to have the expertise on
some of these issues and so I just was
interested in why they were eliminated
from your proposal uh thank you
um the simple reason was that I don't
they think that they were required under
id idea okay all right thank you yes
representative cascadden
thank you chairman lab
I just wonder looking at the language in
the federal law where number 11
representatives from the state Juvenile
and adult corrections agencies
to me that satisfies the language
that I guess is there someone who who
puts this committee together or who
leads the group so that they would use
their
you know they're a knowledge base as to
recommending what agency should be
represented to make sure that the
students that are working on high school
or whatnot I'm just curious as to who
leads that and would that serve that
language serve what we're talking about
um uh I I think there were differences
of opinion on how people were appointed
to the committee okay as a matter of
fact
the statute says appointed by the
governor so in several instances of
parents that I knew who were interested
I went to the governor's office and
asked for their appointment gave him
bios for the people and had them
appointed there are some on the council
who believe that
um they basically should
um have veto power and review anyone who
wants to be on the
um on the committee which I uh
find troubling personally
so I I you know
I I think that for me that was an issue
as well
follow up
so is there a chair of this advisory
committee that would serve say two years
so that they've got some sort of a
you know a structure in replacing
membership and making sure they get the
right memberships
um at the um end of last year beginning
of this year they did appoint a new uh
chair for the committee and they do have
um a spreadsheet of a membership and
vacant positions
yes and how often do they meet
um monthly
can can somebody tell me that for
example on the cardelli amendment line
31 and assess it elsewhere too where you
have two individuals and now we're going
to make one is there any process for
identifying which of the two is going to
have to go
uh flip a coin
I thought I'd decide but
um actually
um I'd have to look back and see
um if
sorry thank you
um if these positions um are actually
filled at this point
um I think I do have a fairly recent
spreadsheet or it could get an updated
one to see yeah because we have the same
situation on line 21. yeah
so
um that would be a
and if this goes in effect 60 days after
passage it means that that process is
going to have to be somehow determined
so they know how to handle that
obviously we need some work on this
so yes representative Hall
thank you again the representative
cordelli
um line 21 you've reduced it from two to
one and it says to the special ed
teacher it doesn't say public school
teacher just says special ed teacher
right yet on and then if you flip over
and go from lines five to ten you've got
a private school you've got a charter
school you've got a homeschooled taking
three seats
versus the one seat on the front page
is that intentional or
just the fact that the ones on the
second page for charter school private
school and homeschool are all required
under federal law
further disrepresentative uh Milan thank
you I mean it may be obvious to others
but what does this group do
[Laughter]
it
I don't mean that as a joke no no no no
I'm serious I don't know if this group
does
um they are uh
well we can read the statute in statute
are their duties
um but I know that um
the state plan that Rebecca Fredette has
talked about
um often
um where there are a number of criteria
this group has input into the state plan
um and um other Provisions that I can't
remember
um advising
um uh the department on issues related
to children with special needs and their
education I think is uh primary so as a
follow-up so it's basically an Advisory
Group to the department would you say I
would say that okay thank you
I can recall when we had this we were
dealing with how we provide services
from the uh regular school to the
charter school and there was a task
force put together an academic Bonnie
was on that and uh there was a report
that was issued with a a laundry list of
recommendations which impacted us as far
as legislation was concerned but it also
was of importance to the department so
they are a group that can you know if we
need to do that type of study and
research on special education issues
that is a group we oftentimes have used
in the past and I'm talking now eight
years ago that I'm familiar with it
represent lackets
just in response to what was asked
earlier on the second page line one it
says one administrator of a public
special education program so there's the
public school being represented on the
second page as well
I
think so rips and home about ready to
move forward here
thank you
um and I and I just want to respond to
the department while they're all
involved right sure well sorry they're
all in law well that's the point of an
amendment right so if they're all in law
that you could have been amended you
know you reduce two features to one
um so at least is my point but I do
think uh in response to representative
Lucas that administrator and teacher are
two separate but the first the teacher
doesn't say public
but thank you no go ahead so
my Amendment simply changes two things
in this big big committee whereas
representative cordelli's Amendment
basically changes the whole committee
um and I think that
the committee is
is important enough that we should have
a time when we get input from maybe
because we we didn't have testimony
um on on changing the whole committee
face of the whole committee
um and I think these changes are pretty
in his his Amendment are pretty
wide-ranging and I I would certainly
like to hear from some of the people
that are on that committee whether they
think that
um you know that this is the way to go
um okay let's try to think about
procedure which we may follow to uh
first of all well we have two amendments
we've been discussing both and both seem
to have legitimate issues one is the the
size of the the committee and then then
we're all talking who's going to be on
it at this point in time I don't want to
end this particular session right here
with a Amendment already proposed I'd
like to have us withdraw this amendment
and have two amendments which we can
take to
either if we retain this bill we can
study the bill and come up with solid
recommendations by November so we could
then act on it then is this so critical
that we have to have something done now
or would are having some time to put a
subcommittee together to look at this
issue through retaining it
and then move forward in November where
the recommendation from the subcommittee
representative yeah uh Mr chair what's
on the floor right now is OTP
there's been no that's right we never
there's no motion on either of these
yeah so there's been no much you're free
to do that so we we can do that
so yes representative
um looking at the statutes and I just
wonder if um
somebody needs to take the lead of this
committee and I know that individual
districts are required by Statute to
have an individual
plan of their special ed program which
which is sort of a spin-off of the state
plan so I know that there has to be a
lot of input on that state plan but it
would seem to me if that's the primary
role the statue says it's to advise the
commissioner of Education of issues
relating to special ed
why isn't the commissioner organizing
this group so that it is has Fair
representation of all the entities that
are required
it's a good question and that's a
subcommittee question that needs to be
addressed and what are the duty specific
responsibilities for this and who they
report to and
Etc so we have a motion on the table
though to OTP this bill
so if we were to withdraw that motion
and then put something forward to retain
the bill then we can get resolution to
both of these amendments and to the
questions which we've had
who made the motion here I did
and who seconded
for me so would you be willing to just
pull back your motion I would withdraw
the ought to pass motion yes represent
power now I would second that okay so so
you're we're both withdrawing so we have
nothing on the table at this point in
time so how about a motion to retain
so moved by representative cordelli
second by Preston Tanner
um
is there any opposition to that from the
committee here I don't think we have to
take a a hand vote well we could
we could take it you've also be on the
record so maybe we ought to just do it
pardon me hand vote Yes we can do a hand
vote on this so all those in favor of
the motion to retain the show with your
hand please anybody opposed good we're
good so that's what we'll do with this
one and we'll put a subcommittee
together
it'll be a 20 20 zip uh to uh look at
this this whole situation uh I will you
know get some members on that
immediately and I don't think this
deserves to committee the whole I think
they can have it
foreign
cordelli and represent Tanner on that
thing where it belongs and
and then rips and little you can be the
third member and we've got that thing
done
oh yeah
yeah so I'll I'll get the subcommittee
members when she's back here so I want
to get people on who want to be on it
all righty
um
so that's that one
all right
we haven't done 577
we haven't done uh
37 and 377.
well do we have the uh amendments that's
represent they're done she's just going
to get them
what she'll be let's let's just take a
break and let her get back to those
amendments and then we'll
continue
this is I don't know if I gave you this
this is my Amendment
437 the reading bill that includes 377.
instead of just the third grade and have
the department find and purchase for
State use a universal
um literacy and dyslexia screener
do you do you have copies of that or no
I haven't submitted it to uh
foreign
use my gym voice here the original bill
that we had
um
the changes that are in the amendment
first of all is to include Charter
Public Schools in this uh so that that's
one of the first ones and then down on
um
let's see
down on line 21
it's changed it was twice
um yearly through second grade and it's
changed to third grade
um
and then on the
second page
um what was changed
was an addition at line 14.
of a subparagraph
and this is probably the biggest change
to the to the whole bill is that an
additional one thousand dollars for each
kindergarten through third grade pupil
in the admr who fails to meet relevant
benchmarks for reading screenings using
evidence-based screening tools such as
diables or equivalent screening methods
for interventions at the school's
discretion so what what this does is
currently
at third grade when the state assessment
is done any student that's not
proficient at that point the school can
then apply for a grant
per student which seems kind of by third
grade I was saying at lunch to somebody
if you haven't taught somebody to I was
a lifeguard if you haven't taught
somebody to swim by 16 it's very
difficult to get them to swim afterwards
and the same thing goes for reading if
they've spent the first three years
really struggling or you know uh they
get to third grade and they still can't
read a lot as we heard in the testimony
a lot of negative
um things happen to them they think
they're stupid they
um often um are falling back and other
things because reading is so essential
to everything so my thought with that
and actually it was kind of
um copycat off uh representative
cordelli's idea for his upcoming bill
that why not give money when when the
reading problem is discovered so that
the money can be used then for
intervention right rather than wait till
third grade and kind of conglomerate
everybody together and just give money
at that point so that's probably the
biggest change other than it applies to
chartered schools
for the town online
foreign
yeah
I'm sorry yes sorry
could you repeat that please and the
answer was what
line 17 is that a thousand dollars
annual
uh so it's it's part of the adequacy
um right now it's just a one-time yeah
okay okay thank you
thank you chairman yeah further
represent Myler
but thank you this is a this query
deals with the actual funding
because one of the problems that we've
had with the reading program when this
goes to finance
is that how do we know the thousand
dollars is in fact going for a reading
program and not going into some dark
hole in the School District budget
so it it it's really a point of interest
of mine I I don't think you've addressed
this here as we have it in the 360 or
the 600 whatever it was but it would
seem to me as we look at this bill
there needs to be some sense of the
receiving School having some
responsibility of saying here's how
here's the interventions that we're
using for this thousand dollars to
ensure that students are in fact you
that the district is committed to doing
this because you are increasing the
amount of money here so it's more of a
statement than really a question that
I'm concerned about because if this goes
if this goes to finance I can tell you
right now uh representative Weiler is
going to be all over this because he's
been all over it before and I think we
need to address the issue before it gets
to finance so that he can say oh you
finally looked at this and there is some
sense of an intervention strategy to
deal with children who do have this
reading problem
I'm sorry Mr Mr chair was not a question
is yeah a comment it tell me
yes represent Ford
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I'm uh not experienced in this area at
all so let me this is a naive question
but I noticed that these deadlines occur
at times like 30 days 60 days and so
forth and I can't help but wonder what
happens between those deadlines
what happens to the student is there any
intervening Catch net or something that
says okay we've identified a problem but
we haven't yet decided what we're going
to do
who holds the student's intellectual
hand while all this is going on
is that for me I guess yes um thank you
so down in line 27. on page one uh and
this is part of the original Bill the
school shall promptly inform the
students parents or legal guardian of
the screening results is special ed
referral is made for further evaluation
the state's required timeline shall be
followed but basically
um this this the point of this bill was
that when they're tested the parents are
notified an intervention start rather
than
um okay let it delay
um my reading didn't get me to the
second part that's why and that's
probably just because I don't understand
the system so
further discussion represent cascadden
you'd have more than one
go for it
is this
um
just to help representative Ford Reading
instruction classroom in a regular
classroom instructions usually a
multi-tiered system of supports
so the first tier is everyone gets the
instruction and the teacher will screen
or assess or realize that there's a
group of children that didn't get it the
first time so then there's extra
intervention provided to that secondary
tier
and then when there are kids that are
not making it after so many weeks of
instruction because you can't determine
a disability a disorder or anything
unless your kids have been had some
sense of formalized instruction for a
period of maybe four to six weeks
so that you know whether they can learn
it or not and knowing that all children
learn at different rates then you've got
the third tier ninety percent of the
time that's a student that ends up being
identified So within a regular classroom
which is a self-contained classroom it's
a multi-tiered system of support so even
if you screen all the students
a student is not going without
instruction in the meantime
so that's an explanation of that the
other thing that I I question is
the bill the current law says
kindergarten first grade and at
appropriate times
it seems to me that if you are testing
every single student K to three
you're spending money on assessment
tools that are not necessary because
it's not going to be a hundred percent
of your kids
that need that screening because they've
already been monitored from say
kindergarten on through the grades and a
teacher will know
who needs to be checked again who needs
to be checked again who needs more
instruction
so I just question that
um the other thing with the time limits
if you have students that come into
first grade that have had no preschool
or kindergarten experience chances are
you know that the teacher is going to be
on that like a dog on a bone just
because you know they haven't had any
instruction yet and they need to be
exposed to it before so that you know
whether they are learning or not in
terms of a time frame of 60 days so a
school calendar
if this relates to school days
you have just about 60 days at the end
of the end of November so November 30th
so I had 58 days in this year's school
calendar
to November 30th so the law says no
later than November 30th so the law
already meets that satisfaction unless
it means calendar days now you're
you're accelerating the need for that
but your kids haven't had a good solid
I mean the beginning of school you're
teaching rules you know basic behaviors
and then you start getting into the meat
potatoes of instruction and kids need a
good six weeks of instruction to see how
they sort out
um
and then the one initiating intervention
within 21 days
I I don't know if there's a need for
that if there's someone in a tier two or
tier three they're either going to go
through a title one program support
system or they have a reading specialist
but I have concerned about small
districts who don't have reading
specialists
so those are the concerns that I have
and I just and and coupled with that is
RSA 200 colon 60 which is reading
Specialists requirement says the
commissioner of the Department of Ed
shall issue a request for proposal to
secure the contract Services of a
reading specialist to enable the
department to provide school districts
with the support and resources necessary
to assist students with dyslexia and
Related Disorders and their families
and so I don't know if that has occurred
because to me that's the precursor to
this
so I just that's a question I don't know
if you know representative Tanner if
there is one
um are we able to
ask the we we can ask and you know you
talk about these timelines and all that
and when we're talking about some of
this reading identification when you're
asking a kindergarten or first grade
teacher to give you a report by anytime
in September
forget it you're not going to get it uh
and so I that's part of the timeline
concern I have on any kind of a bill
that we have
uh in reality you're not going to get it
done but um and this one right here
the there's some lawyer terms here that
they love the word promptly what does
promptly mean
um you know that that's that could
become a question you know you didn't
notify me with one day or two day you
did it after 14 days is that promptly
well in some schools that may be really
early for a notification
um then on on the top part there the
screen shall be repeated one additional
time during the current school year so
the student comes in in April do you
have to do it one more time after that
that doesn't make any sense to me either
uh and repeated a minimum twice yearly
through third grade there may be some
students that are in third grade they're
absolutely having no problems they are
reading now they are not even
necessarily do using your phonics to do
that they may be just good vocabulary
comprehension type readers with fluency
right and and so I I I think what we're
sometimes doing is writing legislation
that's going to cover all ends which you
can't do that the kids are different and
teaching is different and and some of
the policies for these timelines have to
be made locally
and in the classroom
in conjunction with a specialist and and
representative Caden are right we do not
have and we're in my community they're
reading teacher to help we don't have
the money for it and and you know in the
Specialists whereas you have some school
districts have curriculum Specialists
that's an unknown in many of our small
school districts in this state
so I'd be careful with the timeline
business and some of the vocabulary you
can't Define representative Cascade just
just a final to remember that you know
we're trying to make decisions in the
best interest of kids not what we want
but also to trust
in the system
because it does work and know that
children are not carbon copies of each
other nor they all going to fit in the
same box at the same time I mean there's
a wide spectrum of abilities
and it takes some magic as Margaret
would know to be able to juggle all of
the abilities of children so that they
all succeed so just want to keep that in
mind so thanks representative Cornell I
just wanted to reinforce the thing about
kindergarten because depending on where
you live when you enter kindergarten
kids enter with very very different
skill sets even within like Manchester
depending on which area you're coming
from I know one kindergarten teacher her
students entered they didn't know their
colors you know but then you have
another kitten kid well kindergarten in
another part of the city they probably
enter School reading because they've
gone to preschool or or something else
and the other kids are sitting home
watching TV until it's time for
kindergarten
so we have to remember that too not
everybody's entering equal either you
know I recall what my wife said she was
a first grade teacher up in Dillingham
Alaska which the only way you get there
is by plane there's no roads to it it's
Bush Alaska
and she had kids coming in that were oh
just tremendous kids in terms of their
culture
when it came to some of this stuff right
here
and so you know again one shoe doesn't
fit all
going over this side and then represent
Myler
thank you
um
what we have to remember was what was
the
one of the intents of this bill to begin
with is that dyslexic children tend to
be average and brighter
and can hide and that was the point of
doing the multiple testing throughout
that whole time period is to catch those
who
in classrooms seem to be doing fine but
aren't really they're just they've made
up tools to use for themselves they you
know they're they're compensating and
that works until they hit that brick
wall and then you find out that they
can't and this was the whole point of
this was to catch those kids before they
hit that brick wall
yeah mine is really a follow-up to um
representative Tanner asking about the
status
of the reading specialist out of the
department do we know what the status of
that is
do we have any yeah
good afternoon Melissa light division
director for learner Support Department
of Education initially the reading
specialist contractor we were allocated
thirty thousand dollars to contract with
the specialist to provide those Services
as outlined in the RSA
we contracted with a person that was
doing that work for um as long as I've
been at the department which has been
about uh three and a half years
um since
I would say September I believe it was
we were able to hire on our Ela
education consultant that is does have
all of meets all the qualifications and
has all of the background to meet the
reading specialist
um provision so we wanted to um
make a change in the legislation so that
we could reflect that instead of having
to contract that work out as outlined in
the RSA we'd have the ability to have
somebody on staff that could provide a
lot of that that work
um the contractor previously did all of
the um put together all the resources
put together screeners and we have all
of that all those resources and supports
available on our website in addition to
our learning management system all that
can be accessed and there's
um clarifications on the legislation
resources and supports specifically to
meet that requirement and then our Ela
specialist that is currently with the
Department is continuing on that work
she's working on the lean into literacy
initiative where we're doing trainings
across the state in Reading instruction
in addition to looking at providing some
supports at the uh in our teacher
education training programs and that so
she is continuing to do the work that is
outlined in that
but again with one person and a very
very very small allocation to go towards
that we're able to augment a little bit
with the federal funds to have her do
that work but with just one person
um it's we're not able to have her
providing supports to all of the schools
so she's able to provide kind of a
higher level but not necessarily being
able to go in and do trainings at each
and every school across the state
because we just have that one other
follow-up so is it part of the
Department's budget proposal to have
that position full time rather than uh
having to contract it out I I think that
if we were able to use an allocation to
go towards even partially meeting half
of that funding for that position I
think that would help but currently
there's just the thirty thousand dollars
that we are able to use so there's not a
budget item not at this time no okay
thank you president cardelli uh thank
you um I do have a bill coming before us
that will
modify the reading specialist statute so
that it doesn't have to be a contract uh
situation
um that doesn't have an appropriation
with it either but you know who knows we
can we can always mend things right I
think having the flexibility is
important because we have to look at
what is the most um fiscally appropriate
way to to get the services of an expert
in that field we're very very lucky that
we just happen to hire an Eli specialist
that has all of the meets all those
requirements and has that specialty in
her background and if I may uh Mr chair
I think one of the concerns we have is
that this committee and this legislative
body has authorized like a nurse a nurse
coordinator they've authorized a
um a guidance person and yet they have
those positions as they've been
authorized by the by this legislative
body they have not been filled and
followed up with by the department and
so that that's the point that's the
concern that I have as we look at this
important they're all important but in
this particular one that if we're going
to deal with having an individual that
that we as a group feel is appropriate
then I think it's it's incumbent upon
the department I'm not picking on you at
all but it's incumbent upon the
department to recognize that and and to
move forward appropriately uh with the
budget that's all thank you yeah would
you like me to respond to the nurse
position because I can provide an update
if you would like so for the that
particular position we had a difficulty
filling a position that was specific to
that but we were able to hire an
administrator that has an MPA and she is
um
uh able to I'm sorry in an mph a masters
in public health so she is um The Bureau
administrator for wellness and nutrition
so she oversees that entire
um Bureau and that she's able to provide
the specific
um requirements as outlined in the in
the RSA
um to provide those services to the
schools and be that nurse coordinator
position
yes represent Belcher
uh thank you Mr chair I wanted to speak
briefly to um
continue on with some testimony that we
had heard previously especially from the
Department of Education
um when it comes to how often we're
doing this testing we heard testimony
previously that the test itself is
obviously not perfect no test is there
is going to be some number that is a
false positive on this those students
who were false positive on the test are
then going to experience some degree of
of diversion from the normal studies
program as part of this
um so I think what I'm getting at here
is there is there is an optimum number
there has to be given the law of
diminishing returns for how many and how
frequently we're doing these tests
because the more frequently and we do
them the less we're going to be
capturing actual dyslexia the more we're
going to be capturing false positives
so I don't know if we actually know what
that number is because if we go too far
over that number we can't say with any
certainty that we're actually doing more
good than harm in the in the educational
cycle
reps and cascad
thank you
um going back to the statute on the
reading specialist again there is a
section in the other talks about the
commissioner will submit a report about
the effectiveness of the work of the
reading specialist uh to make sure it's
complying with all the requirements and
the law
and that it would give he would give a
copy of that report to the Speaker of
the House the Senate President the chair
people the chairperson of the House and
Senate education committees and the
governor no later than November 1st 2018
and annually thereafter so I'm wondering
if you were you have received such a
report in the fall and that might help
us know how are things going in
specifics
um as part of this discussion
reports are filed by the the
commissioner and we do get them here you
do okay yes we get them in bullying we
get them on various types of activities
that the required to report to us we do
get those reports okay you're right most
of them come in during the summer okay
our our late late spring yeah okay so
there would have been a summary report
of how the contracted service has worked
thus far yeah we can we can we can look
but you know I know there's a number of
reports which we don't receive could you
be able to I provided that report before
November
thank you represent Tanner where so as
committee members where where would we
go to find those reports
online
I think it'd be probably wise of going
right to doe to get them because
oftentimes those reports come here and
that they're
they're provided to us they're provided
to the various people that are required
by stats to be notified but then they
are parked somewhere on a desk whereas
if you well truthfully yeah they've got
to be filed somewhere
and and and so the best place to get it
is inquire directly to the department
and they can get those reports it's just
like the other day we had a question
regarding the reports of the efas and
that scholarship organization the
reports have been submitted
it's just that somewhere after submittal
that that's where all the confusion
starts
yes representative Balboni um yes
concerning those reports just as a new
member
um not knowing where all that
information is and to hear that it's
been filed somewhere you'll be extremely
helpful whether it's an internal I mean
I don't know where you publish that
information but it certainly would help
me in understanding you know all these
um all these issues that are coming up
so thank you unfortunately see they send
it usually to the chair chairs change
the legislators come and they go and all
this other so it's it's just
I guess the whole system that's
rethought as far as how can that be put
out to the committee and then in the
fall committee members in the beginning
of binding all change here we are now
with uh half this committee is brand new
and so with that you obviously haven't
seen those reports we have communicated
some of those other reports copies will
be made I know Jennifer makes copies of
some of those and they're handed out to
committee members uh what goes on after
that I don't know
yeah represent cardelli thank you
I'd like to take a step back if I might
um if you remember HB 437 was a larger
reading literacy initiative what I did
was I Incorporated
377 into that bill in an amendment and
based on the hearing I have gone back
and drafted an additional Amendment not
submitted yet to OLS
but what I did was
um
provided the the reading
um incentive Grant uh program which was
in the original bill for the third grade
I made it for the second and third grade
um because I think in order for
Grants to be made there's going to be
have to be made on a common product
so I also added that the department
would identify a contract with a
universal
literacy and dyslexia screening product
I worked with the Amplified people who
make Dibbles to incorporate some um
measures of what that product should
include
um I added the charter schools
um in terms of
um
speaking to that Universal screener that
the department would get
um I added an appropriation to the bill
for the Department to acquire that
screener for use Statewide
and in in relation to the thousand
dollar reading Improvement Grants
um the bill does require a report from
the district
outlining the plan on how the district
intends to use the grant award funds to
offer into intensive reading
intervention programs so hopefully that
will provide some a measure of how those
funds are being used to actually help
kids rather than the differentiated aid
grant which just goes into a black hole
if you will and this reading Improvement
Grant replaces
um the um differentiated Aid it'll cost
a little bit more but it does replace
that
um
so you know I'm taking a different
broader scope approach to this
um by trying to include dyslexia
um as well as literacy because it's all
based on a screener and looking at
deficiencies also in my discussions with
um the amplify dipples people they have
a product above Dibbles
um includes Dibbles but also
identifies and it's meant to be teacher
given
um at the district level uh it
identifies the deficiencies and also
provides recommendations on
interventions to correct those
deficiencies and has a patient excuse me
I keep doing that apparent portal
uh because one of the requirements is
the bill for uh is for Parental
notification and follow up with the
parents and this
dashboard would help accomplish that
without any additional work on the
district level I think
um so that's what I'm trying to do in
437 I passed a couple of copies around
um I just wanted to get a feel for the
um the effort from the committee before
submitting this again another amendment
to the bill to OLS for drafting
um but that's what my intention is in uh
um this next Amendment
further represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair and I don't
mean to dwell on this point but I'm sure
you didn't mean to say that adequacy
grants go into a black hole um
well that's a that's an adequacy Grant
yeah and and and
um and it doesn't go into a black hole I
think probably what you what you meant
is that districts can use those funds as
they see fit and they certainly report
back out on them in detail in the doe 25
right and it goes into a black hole as
far as knowing whether that money and
it's 1.7 million dollars a year actually
goes to help kids with their reading no
I I I I agree with that right districts
can use it as it sees fit it's a it's
General attic part of General adequacy
funding so thanks
on the other side of the coin you know
1.7 million dollars spread over this
entire State you know if you look at the
amount of money we're fighting in the
differentiated aid for reading is
minuscule and it's you only receive it
if you're not qualifying for the other
three categories so special education
are differentiated eight which are the
special education free and reduced in
English language learner
so
um
if we were requiring accountability and
I've tried to do that in the past uh it
would spend more money trying to get the
accountability report then we're sending
the district for you know improving
ratings
so
yeah
further yes represent woodcock
thank you chairman just to follow up on
representative balboni's uh question doe
the last report that the according to
the the regulation the last report that
the commission's office should have
generated would have been November 22.
as a possible for our you to request
copies
we can just get one report we get it we
give it the job first she makes multiple
copies we all have some based on the
same information yes I provided the
report before November 1st and I can
resend that thank you sure
that'd be fine
are there further questions of the
department
not seeing thank you very much
thank you
so we're back to the that the bill at
South 377.
um
fairly honest thing
okay is there any further discussion on
on uh 377 the amendment yes
um am I correcting the both 377 and 437
early bills
uh visiting
for I'm sorry 437
my mistake for 437 is an early bill yeah
foreign
we have over 40 bills with FNS on it we
have 16 early bills
um
you know that the the second was not an
early right not an early bill so one of
them is
yep
I think
um once you put that extra thousand
dollars and whatever that kind of makes
377 if we amend it with this amendment
also an early Bill and is there a
problem with no it does not no it
doesn't mean it doesn't even though we
add the money we can put a million
million dollars on the thing and it's
not something our question is can we
just recess 377 until we are talking
about
the other one for 437 and then look at
them both together at that point since
they're since we may be amending two
into one if that's what we decide to do
does that make sense
looking at both bills we've got to make
sure the intent of both bills is
closely linked
and I'd have to I'm looking at the
intent on on 377 here the screening of
intervention and the other one is you're
building it uh yes
um or I can um
if for 37. if you'll give me more I have
copies of my amendment that includes
my edition of 377 not the rest that we
just talked about yeah yeah but I have
copies in the office I can get
you know they're both dealing with
similar topics
so they could be joined into one bill
there's no question there
um I I think I would throw out the
caution here though that
for us sometimes it's easy to write
statutory language but we got to also
make sure that the statutory language we
write with all its timelines and
responsibility gels with reality
by that I mean gels with what's going on
in the grade schools
and
um I know the intent is to make sure
everybody's reading and we get kids
reading but to do that I caution on one
shoe fits all it's it's something you've
got to be very careful there are some
schools that probably are using other
programs to try to accomplish this there
are some schools that you know teach
reading differently than another and
there's no set protocol for the state if
we do something like this
yes there's some benefits to it
uh but there's also some going to be
some casualties
so represent cascadden
thank you for making that point
definitely we want kids to read and
definitely we want to be able to support
whatever uh can help support the
districts in that process I caution
about recommending any one particular
tool
because to me that's not our role
to do that whether the state provides
the funding or not and yes I've been
trained in Dibbles and I don't discredit
what you can get from it but I know that
there have school there are schools that
have also used star
and are using a different version of
Dibbles to get to the same information
so I worry about us sitting here making
a decision on a tool when we're not
reading Specialists and we don't you
know we don't really know what a child
might need and I think that's up to the
local school district but definitely if
we can put our heads together I like the
suggestion of Representative Lucas to
look at both bills together to see what
we can do to strengthen reading
instruction
uh for our kids
represent cordelli uh yes I didn't mean
to imply that my draft would require any
one product it would be based on an
evaluation and contract by the
Department of Education
um but I I feel that if we are going to
award grant money based on proficiency
level that you have to have a base it on
a common product
yeah our district also used star math
star reading
uh that there is
there's a lot to this if you look back
over the years in education we've gone
through many swings the pendulum in
education and every time we make a swing
we think we've got the answer then we
swing back and we go from uh inquiry
science do we go to Modern math
mathematics we go to no walls we go to
walls we go to all over the place and
every time we make these changes in
these moves
we're we're messing with education and
to the point where we're taking that
local thread away which is fit to their
particular community and as a result of
their local board and their teachers
working cooperatively together so it's a
challenge uh we know we've got to try to
improve in some areas but the we is
going to have to be the local school
district
and it's not going to be from this level
right here we can say hey we emphasize
that you do this we we want to see
something change but it but we
I don't know I would I would suggest you
all go down and get in the kindergarten
room go down get in the first grade room
and and see what's going on they're all
saying everything you need to know in
life is taught in the kindergarten well
that's true
and and so you know I you know so please
you know before we go with both these
bills and try to you know we got to be
careful be really careful where we're
going that's coming from my experiences
as an elementary teacher and Elementary
principal
and I it was it really it's a challenge
it's a fun job but it's it's very you
know 16 little guys in a classroom in
the first grade is like having a whole
Army in a classroom
I can tell you that
and it takes a lot of work a lot of work
and I can remember when I was a fourth
grade teacher back then in those days it
was 25 28 kids maybe 30 kids in the
classroom and they came down with this
program called Fountain Valley
and we had to and fountains still around
some of the products but at any rate we
had to identify what we were doing in
Reading in terms of every darn fanatic
skill you can believe we had to track
all the Blends the digraphs the constant
short or the constants and the Blends
and and the vowels short and long and
all the all the other uh Associated
skills both in comprehension and
vocabulary
I spent most of my day managing those
charts
and and every time you make a teacher do
that you're subtracting from the
instructional time and the real benefit
that that teacher is in that room for so
I caution I put that caution I think
what we will do is we will recess not
take any action on this and we'll try to
blend the two bills together
see if we can do it
yeah see and we're going to have to we
can't keep putting off these early bills
so we're going to have to do it we're
getting into February
and so when we do the force that's on
Monday so we could also note this one to
be heard on uh you know exact on Monday
I'll have to work around these rules
with with our clerk make sure I do
things right Jennifer keep me in line
here will you please I'll do it my way
if anything that's not going to work
we'll recess this bill
so that means we've recessed what three
bills today
and we'll try to get those on the docket
in the proper locations so that we can
do it with the other bills yes represent
cascadden I'm sorry is the intent of the
Bell to replace the current
uh reading in the disparity Aid would
this replace it
because right now it's um what is that
700 or something per child if they are
reading below grade level by the end of
third grade or by third grade and and I
believe are they using the New Hampshire
State assessment as that measure
with the uh could you could you repeat
yeah
so a thousand dollars per student yes
right okay so is that to replace the
differentiated Aid category of students
reading below grade level and do they
use the New Hampshire State assessment
for that measure because all third
graders take the state assessment that
was in my original bill at what you
state yeah in my new Amendment
um
uh the differentiated Aid is still
eliminated and replaced by this reading
Improvement Grant okay
um the
um the grant would be given in the
second and third grades
so
um in order to have a common base for
warning of that Grant I suggested the
state purchased screener would be used
and then we could uh see where
proficiency work levels were based on a
common platform okay that makes that
makes sense I I understand now why
you're talking Universal screener
because they they all have to take the
same right to get the comparison yes so
that would replace that category of just
disparity right and that 1.7 million
would fold up let's say to the uh the
new level
um and um I was able to get any numbers
from the Department of Education about
uh the number of
um deficient
um second and third grade readers but
what I did look at was uh the second and
third grade enrollment which is about 12
000 students per grade level
um and
um look at proficiency levels which are
generally around 50 percent in Reading
at the state level so that's
um I took that then multiplied that by a
thousand dollars per deficient reader to
get in a ballpark idea of what the cost
of the program would be
so what was your ballpark figure six
million
um uh per year yeah that's what I
calculate right there reporting moments
uh
um six million losing your fingers you
just mention right six million second
grade yeah and six million third grade
um times two years so it's 24 million
boy
buy myself a Cadillac with that
okay
alrighty so I guess we're at the end of
the day on all this uh um so what we
will do is that we have no more bills to
exec today so we're going to end this
executive session
and we'll take these three bills and
hook them on to an exact session at a
time which is best with the other bills
that we'll have to put in the calendar
thank you for all in the audience of
waiting through all this
right and tell Jerry fruit he must have
fun streaming this thing huh
yes can you repeat what bills that we
are yeah okay please
let me go back my machine here
okay the bills which we are going to be
coming up with and putting in 272 that's
the funding of the charter school upping
that a little bit
um and then
um
577 that is the catastrophic Aid 3.5
deal
and the one we just addressed which was
dealing with uh 377 the dyslexia
and of course the other bills which we
were discussing are already on the
agenda for our executive session
next week so what I will do is I'll look
at and try and hook them on to the same
day
but what we've got to be very careful is
when we're reviewing these uh we look at
all the read them over and if you have
questions you ought to be communicating
with folks either with Dave or Mel here
or with myself and Glenn or others on
the committee to try and get that little
note done because if we're going to have
amendments we're going to need those
amendments I'm concerned about all these
timelines when you say 10 days after
doing something you're going to be able
to do this
that ain't going to work it in a school
it's just not going to be possible
um it's and I I've asked uh
representative cat's cabinet Tanner to
look at what we just talked about what
Glenn was just talking about I get a
sense of what what where that fits with
the dyslexic Bill too so yeah yeah
and I'm very cautious of building a
program around one system
that is you know
that's not
sounds like we're looking at textbooks
in Florida and California telling what
we're going to have to do
yeah okay
work session simply no actions taken in
a work session work sessions primarily
for those who need more information or
we need to work more and build and we
have more bills there
free finance and and the direct Medicaid
bill 601.
yeah thank you so much thank you Arlene
we've gone on to that very quickly and
I've
librarian network is
it's like going to a college classroom
this is how you're going to do it
there